Hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week for
my Korra bonus video I wanted to do a breakdown
of all the specialized sub bending techniques.
Book 3 is all about explaining the sub style
of Airbending via Jinora, so I'll explain
that too. They haven't been super explicit
when they mentioned it on the show, but Jinora
had a few lines that summed it up.
Hello any new peoples, if you're just finding
me for the first time I do Korra videos every
week. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I'm even doing a special Comic Con giveaway
that i'll explain at the end of this video.
So up to Book 3 we've seen a substyle for
all the major bending forms. I remember when
Book 2 was getting ready to be released last
year they talked about creating the new substyle
to Air. But when Book 2 came and went with
no explanation everyone was a little WTF confused.
Especially when Jinora deus ex machina saved
Raava and Korra in the finale.
Technically that was the substyle, the way
they showed it in Book 3 looked a little different,
but it's projecting your spirit. Jinora's
words when she was explaining it to Kai were
"It's a high level airbender move, with some
spiritual stuff thrown in."
That actually made me laugh a little because
during the Korra Book 2 dvd commentaries.
Mike and Bryan talked about Jinora's Raava
rescue. They explained that they didn't know
what she was doing. They just wanted to see
her resuscitate the little piece of Raava
that was inside UnaVaatu.
But for all intents and purposes, think of
the Air substyle as Spirit Bending. Not to
be confused with Energy Bending, which could
be considered a sub-style of all forms of
bending even though it's classified as a separate
form.
Jinora having the deepest connection to the
spirit world aside from Korra would of course
be the one to Demo a new style. I love how
the series just brushed over the fact that
she discovered it without any help. Since
we don't see a lot of Jinora scenes I'm guessing
she did sit down and work it out at some point,
Mike and Bryan just decided not to show us
the montage of her figuring it out.
The other interesting thing to note is that
it is a passive ability. It's not used as
an attack ability like the other sub forms.
Here's a breakdown of all the rest.
Next on the cool list right is Combustion.
There's actually three sub forms of fire bending
including lightning generation and lightning
redirection but Sparky Sparky Boom Girl is
killing it right now, so let's start with
that.
Combustion is really the channeling of your
chi through a focused point. Denoted by the
Third Eye Tattoo all Combustion benders have
like Sparky Sparky Boom Man in last airbender
and now P'Li on Korra.
It's more of a focused heat blast than a searing
burn you'd get from regular firebending. It's
true that Azula and other prodigy firebenders
can bend blue flame which is way hotter. But
in terms of blast damage, Combustion is much
more effective.
It's not like a machine gun though, because
you have to focus your chi it takes time to
generate the attack. If you lose focus, like
when someone throws a boomerang at your face,
the blowback can kill you. Like the kickback
from a giant gun squishing your brains.
As of right now on the show, Combustion Man
and the new Red Lotus firebender are the only
ones known to possess the ability. But it's
not a genetic thing, it's all about spiritual
alignment.
Lightning Generation and Redirection are much
more common sub styles. Creating lightning
requires you to separate the positive and
negative energies in your body, like yin and
yang in a physical sense.
When you're able to control the interaction
of postive and negative energy, the bender
guides it outward towards the finger tips
and the resulting charge leaves their body
in the form of electricity. They call it lightning
because it's discharged.
The charge of the blasts can be regulated,
like using a dimmer switch on a light bulb.
Iroh claims he created Lightning redirection
as an answer to waterbending. Redirecting
the charge using your body as a conduit.
One of the coolest things I saw when I first
started watching Korra was learning that Firebenders
were using Lightning bending to generate electricity
at power stations in Republic City. It totally
makes sense that as bending becomes more sophisticated
it starts being used as a commodity.
Bloodbending and Healing are the to Water
Substyles
During Last Airbender Hama claims she's the
first one to figure out Bloodbending. Just
realizing that people are mostly made of water,
but I always wonder if she and Iroh for instance
are just the first people to be recorded talking
about special bending techniques. So when
someone says I'm the first ever in the history
of the world, just take it with a grain of
The reason why Yakkone, Amon and Tarrlok were
able to do it without the use of the full
moon was because one, they were just powerful
benders to begin with and two, they had extensive
training.
When bloodbending it looks like you're making
a person move against their will, but really
what your doing is manipulating the liquid
in their bodies. Every organic process in
your body requires water molecules. H20. They
coat membranes that float around in all parts
of your body, most notably around your bones
and your muscles. So by moving those, it makes
it look like your making their muscles move.
The reason it's so hard to do is because you're
focusing on those small molecules that coat
the muscles.
On the flipside Healing is a slightly less
powerful but way more practical sub form.
It involves using the life giving properties
of water in an energy based context. So you
can treat certain types of wounds and because
it's energy based you can detect problems
with a person's chi.
Unalaq was also able to use this to quote
unquote Heal Dark Spirits. I know they didn't
explain that in book 2 very much. But he's
using a slight variation on Katara's healing
ability to calm spirits which he then taught
to Korra.
Part of the reason I think Korra wasn't able
to heal the spirit vines in Republic City
is because there wasn't anything wrong with
them. If they had been Dark Spirit vines I
think it would have worked. But they weren't
attacking the buildings or going crazy in
an unnatural way.
Metalbending is also one of my favorite substyles.
In addition Toph and Lin Beifong's Seismic
ability and Lava Bending are described as
Earth sub styles.
Metalbending is a little bit like Bloodbending
the earth. What you're doing is bending the
trace unprocessed parts of earth elements
in processed metals. So the more impure or
unprocessed a metal is, the easier it is to
bend.
You're bending the little bits that are unprocessed,
like a Bloodbender bends the little bits of
water covering your muscles.
The reason Toph says she can't bend platinum
is because it's a pure metal, there are no
bits of regular earth left, it would be like
a bloodbender trying to bend sand in the desert.
Even though technically at night there is
moisture in the desert air.
The Seismic ability is something Toph learned
from the badgermoles as a way to navigate.
Since she was blind she had to learn to get
around on her own. It does require you to
feel vibrations on naked skin, so that's why
she always walks around without shoes.
I wonder how many times she had to wash her
feet everyday.
Lava Bending is something we've seen Gazan
do, this is a small contradiction of the way
it's explained in Last Airbender. During that
series it was explained that only a fully
realized avatar could lava bend because it
involved the concurrent use of firebending
and earth bending.
But since we saw Gazan do it on Korra I'm
guessing that a normal bender can heat the
rock just using friction from the air. Gazan
just gets it spinning so fast that the air
friction heats it to melting point and he
fashions it into a superheated blade.
This is pretty small scale though, Avatar
Roku was able to erupt a volcano and Avatar
Kyoshi used it to separate Kyoshi Island from
the mainland.
Energy Bending predates all other forms and
currently there's no sub style associated
with it. That doesn't mean someone won't develop
one eventually. It's when someone bends the
life energy inside a person.
Right now we know Energy Bending can be used
to take away or restore a person's bending
and impart knowledge instantly. It's been
suggested that when the Lion Turtles were
giving Bending to people in Avatar Wan's time,
they were doing so using energy bending.
So I guess if Korra ever developed the ability,
she could bestow bending on a non-bender.
But it's still the biggest question mark of
all the bending styles.
So Big Korra book 3 update: They've released
the titles of all the rest of the episodes.
Here's the rest of the season in order. Episode
6 and 7 tonight are called Old Wounds and
Original Airbenders respectively. Episodes
8 and 9 are called The Terror Within and The
Stakeout. Episodes 10 and 11 are called Long
Live the Queen and The Ultimatum and the two
part finale, episodes 12 and 13 are called
Enter the Void and Venom of The Red Lotus.
I'll wait to speculate on what those titles
imply till my episode review tonight. Be sure
to subscribe to get that. I'll post it around
10PM Pacific Time.
Here's the deal with my Comic Con giveaway
next week. I'm still doing my regular weekly
Korra giveaway, but in addition, next week
I'm also giving away a Pabu plush doll, Naga
doll or Appa, winner gets to choose which.
All you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
I'll leave the giveaway open till the week
after comic con so all you guys have a chance
to see this.
I will be at comic con and I will record the
panel. That's happening next Friday. So I
should be able to upload the panel by that
night. I'll also be posting my episode reviews
because they're airing episodes 8 and 9 that
night too.
Right now click here for my Episode 7 and
8 review and click here for my episode 5 and
6 video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!